regularly once a month or so I've had an
email saying have you come across gage
blocks do you know what gate blocks are
you know they stick together how do they
stick together do they do what's going
on there is it due to a vacuum is a due
to Reese is it due to something else so
so what a gauge but suddenly I don't
even know you talking about bread so I
had very little knowledge of what a
grades blog was until actually this
morning when I did I decided I finally
take a look and go down to the workshop
and talk to our wonderfully talented
technicians and they have got a number
of boxes of these h-blocks so these are
like measurement standards a very
precise machine to be a certain number
of millimeters so the surfaces are
incredibly smooth incredibly flat
machine to be really really flat and
what you can do is you can take two
gears blocks and just by pushing them
together get them stick no glue no
jiggery-pokery no magnetism there's a
stick and what they made us just pure
steel which seems quite magical and so I
want to try and attempt to do this it's
a bit of a skill sometimes it seems to
work sometimes it seems to not work I am
sure the brady has ever will leave in
all the attempts that don't work but
let's let's see what i'm going to do
first of all is just just put a little
bit of acetone on and clean off any crud
that's on on the smooth face that's
relatively clean there and let's clean
this one off that you drive now has to
turn back no there's no acetone left now
I'm using the acetone to just take off
any crud that's on and I don't think
this is gonna work I know that I didn't
know so the way you meant to do it is
actually twist around to 90 degrees but
I've never nearly I think i lured this
yeah we are you just cleaning it again
technicians no okay yes yeah no
technicians use it all the time it's not
just a trick it it's a way of stacking
them up and the reason why it was
introduced like this is because they
didn't want to have a whole set of
different calibration gauges and this
makes it much more straightforward to
them to start them up if you can get it
a bloody work almost
now we can still keep still for me so
they like stuck their fill two stuck
together yep and you know for two
gravity doesn't care so that's you know
it's a fairly hefty block and it's being
held on there against the force of
gravity what makes it happen so that's a
that's been a question that people have
I'm getting getting clean okay that not
and that's a question that people have
asked a lot on awful lot over the last
century of London 20 years something
like that as to what the heck is going
on
so it's an effect that you see when you
have very smooth surfaces now it just
doesn't have to be steel over here I've
got a couple of silicon wafers these are
very smooth as well and what I'm going
to do is I'm going to put one on top of
the other and apply a bit of pressure
hopefully without cracking that here we
go okay same idea what's going on there
- very - very sweet so so there are
number of different things first of all
everything around us to a greater or
lesser extent is covered with a thin
film of water depends on how hydrophobic
how much it doesn't like water or
hydrophilic as surfaces to a certain
extent all surfaces were covered with a
molecularly thin film of water so that's
one aspect of it on a molecular level
that acts as a sort of glue but even
beyond that what's remarkable great
aspect of who put it the statistics of
quantum physics in action but in this
case the silicon wafers for example have
got a thin film of oxide that's
relatively hydrophilic it likes water
similarly with the metal here relatively
hydrophilic quite likes water however in
the case of the silicon what you can do
is you can take a silicon wafer dip it
into haiku fluoric acid strip off all
the oxide and end up with a very
hydrophobic surface so as soon as you
put water on it it beads or toes will
still bond and the reason they still
bond and these were still bond in vacuum
even when you remove the water the
reason they still bond is over here
you've got fluctuating electrons over
here you've got fluctuating electrons
and it's something called the van der
Waals effect and any given instant of
time there's a little dipole there's a
little imbalance of charge so that
you've got a region which is slightly
more positive compared to
another region and those dipoles
interact and snap things together so a
whole area in the semiconductor industry
called where for bonding based on this
let's not let ones positive on one no no
no absolutely no it so it's exactly the
same effect happens in in atoms so xenon
for example you can condense that to
format xenon solid and that's not
because electrons are being shared or
electrons are being transferred as an ax
covalent or an ionic bond what's
happening is it's this Van der Waals
effect it's it's because there are
fluctuations of the electrons which
means that it's not like you've added a
positive charge it means that if the
fluctuations of electrons then this bit
slightly got more electrons over here
than it is over here so there's a tiny
tiny dipole and it's those dipoles that
give rise to this this force even though
there's no transfer of charge even
though there's no sharing of electrons
it isn't an ionic bond it isn't a queer
valent bond it's called the van der
Waals force it's exceptionally important
and that's what's certainly contributor
alongside any liquid film that might be
there to what's holding these things
together so you might be wondering why
doesn't it sort of work in the opposite
direction as well why doesn't it
correlate so that they just fly apart in
terms of the way the charges line oh
it's so key thing that can happen is
that the dipole that forms here on that
instant moment of time it can induce it
can influence the electrons over here
and includes them in such a way so that
the net attraction that that happens
there why did the surface have to be so
smooth why don't you and I stick to each
other so that's a really good question
so you need to lose because you want
those and if you have asperities there
if you've sharp it's then what happens
is your forces don't add up in the right
way you don't get the interactions more
all with the liquid film is important
the fact that you've got a very rough
surface means that that water film that
liquid film can't act as a glue in the
same way in some state called an
entangled state that's all we need to go
into you send one particle to one end of
the universe if the universes ends the
other particle to the other end of the
universe you make a measurement on this
one and here's the weird bit the bit but
course causes so many physicists so many
sleepless night